beaucoup d'ambiance également à
marseille ça chauffe et sur la canebière
et aux alentours de bio port hier soir
et oui sur cette grande fête voyons tout
de suite le reportage de patrice blais
et jean-françois giorgetti
à marseille l'om n'est jamais bien loin
de la fête cette nuit ils étaient des
milliers dans les rues des centaines
dans ce lieu culturel la friche de la
belle de mai une ancienne usine vous est
désormais aux artistes marseillais
la fête à 11 ans indispensable pour tous
juste une question de dose
important que ça existe
et la mise au placard
mais la fête n'est pas qu'un programme
chacun puise son inspiration dans la
musique comme il veut là où il veut
spontanée
tu vas la rue tu vas au panier tu as des
minots de 5 6 ans des types lac qui vont
jouer les cons gars qui vont jouer c'est
pas parce qu'on leur a dit fête la
musique c'est parce que ils sont la
musique à l'imiter et lahoud je crois
qu'il ya une intéressant d'être ici
parce que c'est sa vie en même temps sa
vie ailleurs sans qu'on en dise de vivre
nostalgie pour finir de marseille à
buenos aires il n'y a qu'un pas
le retour du tango place de l'opéra une
autre manière de fêter la musique
il faut faire comme laurence elle est
une bonne recette elle chante on écrit